- [Monique] Those are big boys.
And then I'm at Wendell Park
and he was like, "Oh,
you guys had a tough one
"in the Rivalry Series."
(Gary laughs)
Like okay, I wasn't there.
(chuckles)
- [Gary] How's your day goin'?
Did you guys fly in?
- Took a train in,
from Philly, last night, or this morning.
Last night, we were (mumbles).
So, yeah, just a quick
train, this morning.
- [Gary] I love trains.
- [Monique] There's no
trains in North Dakota, so.
- [Jocelyne] We have an Amtrak.
- [Monique] Not like here, though.
- [Gary] Not like the
infrastructure, yeah.
- [Monique] There's one
train track to get on, so.
- [Jocelyne] I'm just
sayin' we have trains.
- [Monique] You don't
take the trains to get
from point A to point B, so it's.
- Ready to go?
Hey everybody, it's Gary
Vaynerchuk and this is episode 319?
319 of the AskGaryVee Show
and I'm super excited,
we're on a, on an athletic kick
here on the AskGaryVee Show.
Great show yesterday, and
today I have the great pleasure
of introducing two incredible women,
who I've been able to follow
because, obviously they've done
some work through a client
here at VaynerMedia,
so I've been able to watch from afar
and watch some of the content
and I'm really excited to introduce them
and I'm really excited they're here,
and they took a train this morning,
which there's only one
train track in North Dakota
and then we'll go into all that.
But why don't you introduce
yourselves to the VaynerNation?
- I'm Jocelyne.
- I was gonna say, can
you tell us apart, but?
(laughing)
- [Gary] I can.
- But you gave it away.
- I'm Jocelyne.
- And I'm Monique Lamoureux.
We're the Lamoureux twins
and we play hockey for
the U.S. women's team,
but we're currently on maternity leave,
so we're going to camp in a few weeks,
tryin' to get back on
the national team, so.
- And so, right to the origin story,
how do these twins from,
and you were born in?
- [Monique] North Dakota.
- How do these twins
from North Dakota get to
a place where they get to represent
our country at the highest
levels in their sport?
- Well we grew up, so our
dad played Division I hockey,
at the University of North Dakota.
We have four older brothers that
all played hockey and then
we just kind of followed them
around when we were younger.
- [Gary] And you were the youngest?
- Yes, we were the youngest.
- Yeah, so we're 30
and then well there's one
more birthday this summer.
Right now it's 30, 31,
32, 33, 34, our ages.
- [Gary] Your parents were busy.
- Yes, they're crazy.
- [Gary] Clearly.
- Irresponsible.
- So, we would just follow them around,
playing whatever sports they were playing,
but hockey is the big thing.
We have long winters there
and so we'd literally, play
outside on the frozen pond
by our parents house and
we grew up being able to
compete at a high level,
went to a boarding school
right outside Minneapolis.
- And at the earliest
levels you were playing,
obviously mixed with boys
and things of that nature?
- With all boys, we actually didn't have
a girls team to play on
and so yeah there just
weren't enough girls playing,
so we played with boys until high school.
Yep, and then we went
to a boarding school.
- I need one or two great stories on this,
'cause, obviously boys
are idiots and probably--
- [Sisters] Yep.
- And probably grossly underestimated you
so I'm sure there's gotta be,
I need one classic story
that you guys love to tell.
- Our dad always told,
so we played three years
of checking and so when
we started checking
we were probably middle of pack size-wise
before all the boys
started hitting puberty
and our dad always told us
in practice or in a game,
he would say, "Find the the
biggest kid on the other team
"and you put 'em on their ass."
That's what he would tell us.
- [Gary] And you listened blindly?
- Yep.
- Oh yeah, we listened and
then I specifically remember,
it was our peewee year
and I played defense
and so I had knocked
a kid over pretty good
and our coach came back, and he goes,
"Hey don't hit him so hard, next time."
and then he started
walking away and he goes,
"Don't listen to me," he goes,
"you do you keep doing that."
- Interesting.
- You remember, it was Brandon
Lunik that told us that.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- Yeah, I mean, as they get
older and start to realize,
okay it's not cool to have
girls on your team or--
- [Gary] Yeah, the dynamic
changed a little bit.
- The dynamic, yeah it
changed quite a bit,
and so some of the things
guys, very not appropriate for.
- Yeah, especially in today's environment.
- Yeah, very not appropriate,
but some of the things they would say,
"Oh, the girls are the
best players on your team."
Well, our team's beating yours, so.
- I see, so got it.
There was from the opposing team,
they would kind of like talk about that.
- Yeah so I mean you're saying that yet,
I mean, just not the smartest.
- And how did you guys think
about it, obviously thinkin'
about your age, at that
point where were we,
educate me here a little bit,
where were we with Olympic female hockey?
- So, the first Olympics
for women's hockey was '98.
- [Gary] '98, so how old were?
- We were eight, we were in first grade.
- Were you fucking pumped?
- [Sisters] Yeah.
- Did that hit your radar?
Were you like, wait a minute?
- [Sisters] Yeah.
- Yeah, we played a bunch
of sports, growing up,
and our mom was a huge Olympics fan,
so whenever the Olympics
were on, we were watching,
not just hockey, we were just watching--
- Was your mom one of those people
that loved the back story and,
- Yep, loved the stories.
- Yep, oh yeah.
- Costas would get her
so into the farm girl
and now her whole life
predicated on 8:18 p.m.,
to watch the rings, to make
sure that little farm girl won.
- [Sisters] Yep.
- Classic Olympic marketing.
- Yeah, our mom just
loves it all so we just,
whatever sport we were
playing at the time,
'cause we play a ton
of sports, growing up,
it was, we're gonna go--
- What was your favorite sport growing up,
actually on that note?
What you liked the most,
not necessarily what you were best at.
- Aside from hockey, I
would say soccer and--
- But hockey was number one?
It was such a religion in your family.
Was that what it was?
- If it wasn't the wintertime
though, we love like soccer.
- But I mean pure joy,
out of you, actually,
and you're, call it six to 12 years old,
if the world said you
can only play one thing,
not where your opportunities are,
what do you enjoy the most, was it hockey?
- I would say was hockey and soccer.
- Yeah.
Hockey and soccer.
We loved it.
- Well, in North Dakota,
I don't know how it is New York,
but in North Dakota you can play--
- It's definitely very
different than North Dakota,
from New York, I promise you.
I don't know where you're
going, but it's different.
- You can play high school varsity sports
as a seventh and eight grader
so we played varsity soccer
and ran cross-country on varsity
as seventh and eight graders
and so we were as 12 and 13 year olds,
we were playing with juniors and seniors
in high school in soccer and we loved it
and we did really well
so I would say soccer
if it wasn't hockey for sure.
- And so let's keep going
through the progression.
You go to boarding school.
- [Jocelyn] Yep.
- Where'd you guys,
you guys went together?
- [Jocelyn] Yes.
- Was there ever a consideration
to not be together?
Did you guys go through that phase?
- Because we left home at
that age, our parents--
- [Gary] How old?
- We would have been 15.
They only went that early
because we were together.
- [Gary] It made them feel comfortable.
- Yeah, it was definitely I think
a comfort thing for our parents,
but we went to Shattuck-St. Mary's,
which is a pretty
prestigious hockey school.
- [Gary] Top five kind of school?
- Probably, top.
- Sydney Crosby, Nathan
MacKinnon, Zach Parise.
You could name umpteen NHL guys.
And us two and then Brianna
Decker, Amanda Kessel,
we we're all on the
last two Olympic teams,
three for us, but they've produced
a number of pretty good hockey players.
- So, huge program.
- [Sisters] Yes.
- Women's team.
- And were you guys good?
I mean, I know you guys were good.
Did the team?
- Yeah, we won three out of
four national championships,
the four years were there.
- [Gary] I would say that's good.
- It's pretty good.
- So let's really focus
in on the one you lost.
- [Monique] We're still
mad about the one--
- [Jocelyn] Yeah, I know.
- I'm being dead serious.
I love losing, it drives
the shit out of me,
so I'm actually very curious.
What year did, so these were
your four high school years,
in theory, so which year did you not win?
- [Sisters] It was our senior year.
- Fuck you.
- Yeah.
- I know.
- No.
You were completely convinced,
you're like wow, we're
gonna win all, right?
- We out shot the team 42 to 11,
in the quarter finals.
- The goalie stood
on her head?
- Yeah, it was probably the best game
she's ever played in her entire career.
- Do you hate her deeply?
- I don't know who she is but yes.
- Yep, still mad about it.
- So wait, in the quarter finals?
- [Jocelyn] Yeah.
- Was the whole place stunned?
- [Sisters] Yeah.
- You guys were three-time defending.
- Still stunned, still stunned.
- Yeah, we're still mad about it.
- Is that your most devastating loss?
- Oh, Sochi, gold medal game.
- No, Sochi.
- Olympics, still--
- [Gary] Kills you.
- Still mad about that one.
So background around that,
we were up two to nothing,
with about three minutes left in the game.
- [Gary] I remember
these highlights, fuck.
- It's comin' back to you?
It's comin' back to me.
- [Gary] It came back real hard.
- Yeah, they came back, tied
it up with a minute left.
We go into overtime, lose in overtime.
So that was, even though we won in 2018--
- How often will you think
about that game in real life?
Do you think about it once a
year, once a day, once a month?
- I think, well now that we're parents,
it's not as I would say...
- [Gary] You're able
to think about it less?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Yeah, fair enough.
'Cause you're busy, you're
parenting, it's perspective.
But I would say when we think about
our hockey career, there's always--
- [Gary] Well that, of course.
- Yeah, you say you hate losing
and it's you hate losing
more than you love to win.
- But I'm talking more like,
back to parent life, right?
You're driving to the supermarket
and for some reason, you think about,
fuck, what if I just back checked that.
I just think about, I
think about this shit
in pick-up basketball that
nobody on earth remembers,
so I'm like man, real
fucking greats at their...
For everybody who's listening
that has any context
for hockey that that's an
unusual thing to happen
in a hockey match,
especially at that magnitude.
And you start thinking
about, I don't know,
I just think about, do
you think about, oh fuck,
did I hit the post in the second period
and it would've been three, nothing?
I don't know the nuances of the game,
of that specific game, but I just wonder,
especially the way you framed it up.
When you grew up in a
family that is framed up
the way you guys just framed it up,
I don't think people, you know it's funny,
I associate with athletes a lot
because of entrepreneurship.
I'm a very unique entrepreneur
and the fact that entrepreneurship,
you know what's funny?
I actually associate with things
like women's hockey quite a bit.
Let me explain.
In the '80s and '90s,
entrepreneurship was not a thing.
This was the thing, it was called school,
and you had to go to
a good college to be--
- [Monique] Is that your report card?
- This is my horrible report card.
So, in the 80, you know, right now,
I'm living a very interesting life,
where entrepreneurship is cool
and everybody wants to be one,
but when I was really
doing it and sacrificing,
I mean, that's a bad report card.
You know, when I was doing that,
I was a purebred entrepreneur,
as similar as I could get to somebody
who would go away to boarding school
to be there for hockey
and obviously you have to
keep up your grades to be on the team.
All that stuff, but it was underrated.
People thought I was a
loser, even though I was
making all this money
selling big sports cards,
on the weekend, but
because I got Ds and Fs,
my friend's parents thought I would
never amount to anything.
It was that much of the religion.
Anyway, just knowing how I
grew up where everything,
and it wasn't less about my parents,
'cause my dad was just
working all the time,
but it was more like, for
me, it was always in the air.
Back to the, I'm imagining
pictures in my head,
of you guys eating peas and
trying to score on each other
with your brothers with the fork.
It's just in the DNA.
- Yeah, when you think of elite athletes
and people that are at
the tip of the spear
at whatever they're doing you
look at youth sports today
and everyone's like oh, I'm gonna go to,
they specialize early,
they put their kids in all these things,
but then when you look at the tip of spear
of who's been successful,
they're willing to do
what no one else is doing,
when they get when they get older,
when it's appropriate to be specializing,
and everyone thinks they want to do it,
but then when you get
down to the day-to-day,
of what it takes to get to that level.
- [Gary] Sacrificing
everything, social life.
- People aren't actually
willing or wanting to do that.
- [Gary] I couldn't agree more.
- Even when you get to the top of the top,
there's still people
not willing to do that.
- Yeah, at the top of the top, again,
you guys have better framework than I do,
but I'm so passionate about it.
I look at it very carefully.
My brother and I also have
an NFL sports representation
business where we have 25 guys.
I'm sure you saw this.
I don't know how you guys
equate for yourselves,
how hard you worked or
what sacrifices you made,
but at the top of the top
when you see that passiveness,
you have to marvel at the
extreme talent, right?
I'm sure you've seen people who've just
not put in the work that
have made the Olympic team,
or your competitors,
and you're like, fuck,
she is just so fucking talented.
Now, a lot of those players tend to leave
so much on the table
and they could have been
a top 10 player all-time
versus a non all-star.
That's where the variable comes in.
- Or they had it being
a one-time Olympian,
versus a two or three time Olympian.
- Correct, but I think,
probably from your perspective,
you still marvel at the sheer talent
to even get to the top
of the top without--
- Yeah, I mean, we were in New
York, was it two years ago?
For, it was the year out
event for Pyeongchang
and we went to, was it the Knicks game?
- It was our first NBA
game it was actually
the game that Charles Oakley--
- [Gary] Got dragged out
of Madison Square Garden.
- Yeah, but we were a
couple rows off the floor
and we enjoy sports, but
not huge NBA fans, but--
- [Gary] Understood, the speed, the speed.
- The speed, and you just
don't appreciate it on TV,
but when you're on the floor,
like 30 feet away from them.
- It's actually my favorite
thing about hockey,
when I've taken people from
other countries to a game,
or when I was a kid,
just the amount of times
that I've serendipitously through business
been at a hockey game where
somebody rarely watches hockey
has also skated at the rink for Christmas
and within the first five
seconds just completely
gets flabbergasted at the skill level
of the skating needed.
It's similar to the speed
it takes for somebody
to actually be in the NBA.
- Yeah, it's impressive and those--
- They're huge.
- They're so big and the
little space that they have
to work in, with, we were impressed.
- What are you guys about now?
What is what is your passion right now?
Obviously we have, in two years,
this video will be watched
hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of times.
What are you guys passionate about?
What are you trying to put into the world?
- So we just actually launched
our foundation last night,
so we are celebrating.
- Okay, good timing.
That was a layup question.
- [Sisters] Yeah.
(laughing)
- Teed it up, nice.
We're really excited, so
we just launched the--
- [Gary] What's it
called, what it's about?
- Monique and Jocelyne
Lamoureux Foundation
and we've been very fortunate to travel
the country with Comcast as ambassadors
for the corporate values initiatives.
So we're using our platform
as Olympic athletes
to give back and that's been amazing to do
on a national level and to travel,
but now we basically asked ourselves
what can we do on a day to day?
What are we really doing
in our own community?
So we felt like launching a foundation
was the way to do that,
so we're gonna give back.
Our first initiative is
we're going to announce soon,
but probably will be with
the school lunch program.
Yeah.
- Yeah, and our credo is
cheer for the one behind,
so our mom when we were younger,
all the different sports we do,
if it was ever something
that we were competing
against each other,
swimming or cross-country
or whatever it was, it
was, I'm gonna cheer
for the one that's behind,
because she didn't want
to have to pick one over the other.
- First of all, I'm
already all about your mom,
because I'm also, by default,
more underdog nature.
I've watched a lot, I actually was,
it's funny you guys went there.
I was about to ask you
a question about this
and it's been funny, I
noticed, the same reason
everybody in New York is
wearing Steph Curry jerseys,
because people are bandwagon fans,
because they don't have
their own self-esteem,
and I've watched a lot of parents
actually cheer for the kid that's better
and I've always been fascinated
by that because I love this
cheer for the one, that would
absolutely be the way for me,
so I'm a huge fan of your mom.
- She's great, she makes a good latte too.
- Yeah, she does.
- [Gary] Really?
- Linda's lattes, yeah.
- [Gary] Is that a thing or you guys?
- Oh, no, we just tell her.
- Yeah, India knows.
- Oh, have you had one?
- [Gary] India, you know
about Linda's lattes?
- [India] Yeah, their mom gave
me a latte, they're really--
- India, why don't we
open one in Portland?
- [India] Great, I love it.
- Me, you, and the mom team up,
three-headed monster.
(laughing)
I'm telling you I know how to, I can help.
- [India] I know.
(laughing)
- Okay.
- Yeah, so we, that's
kind of something that,
for us it kind of transcended sports
and just into other parts of our lives.
I remember, at the time I
didn't think anything of it,
but in sixth grade,
there was a kid that sat
next to me, we sat alphabetical order.
He had Down syndrome, his name was Justin
and he would sit by himself
at lunch I was like,
"Hey Justin, why don't
you come sit with us?"
So at a table of 10 girls,
he'd come and sit with us
and he kind of became the cool kid.
So that was in sixth
grade, by eighth grade
he would just migrate from table to table.
- [Gary] Love you.
- And then unbeknownst
to us, I think his mom?
I think his mom or grandma
sends a letter to the school
and then they sent it to our parents.
I didn't tell my parents
about it, it was just.
- [Gary] Yeah, it's life.
- Just being nice.
So then actually we were doing an event
a couple months ago and his
grandma can't come to the event
and then we're doing a quick
meet-and-greet afterwards
and she was like, "I'm Justin's Gram."
I'm like, "Oh my God,
it's Justin's Grandma."
So it was just little things like that
where we're just trying to be nice
and just be a good person.
- Kindness is so underrated.
- [Monique] Yes, it is.
- I push it so heavily,
I'm fascinated by people
not understanding how life actually works.
- Well it just doesn't make, like what?
- [Gary] It makes no practical sense.
- Why go through life that and be a dink?
- Well why, because,
unlike the three of us,
we were fortunate enough
to have a situation
where we weren't hurting inside
and it wasn't manifesting.
When I watch people not be kind,
I deploy empathy and
sadness for that person
because I'm like what's
really going on back home,
is super not interesting.
- [Jocelyne] Mm hm.
- That's the manifestation
of a bad environment
or bad parenting or a
terrible circumstance.
- [Jocelyne] Mm hm.
- You know?
Nonetheless, what is the biggest fight
you two ever got into?
Go.
- Against each other?
- [Gary] Against each other.
- Oh, against each other?
- Well, you know what?
I'll share this.
I had braces
and I also--
- and you didn't?
- No, I probably should have though.
- I also had to wear
headgear when I was at home.
I didn't have to wear
it in public at least.
- Why'd you have to wear,
- We would make fun of her.
- Oh, the headgear for
the braces, understood.
- We would make fun of her
- Like some old 1980s shit
- and go like this.
- Yeah, all my brothers
would make fun of me.
- [Gary] Just call you this?
- Yeah.
- Love.
You guys were so unstoppable.
I always think about the
reason I'm unstoppable
emotionally is all the bad
stuff happened so early,
like didn't speak English,
I was an immigrant,
got picked on, terrible in school,
everybody thinks I'm a loser,
wasn't athletically inclined enough,
that very quickly my hand-eye
coordination skills went away
by third grade and I'm losing,
and so it's like, loss,
loss, loss, loss, loss,
that by the time I became a grown up,
I'm like fuck all of
you, I don't give a fuck.
And just thinking about having the luxury
of having four alpha athletic brothers
be older than you, I'm like wow,
these ladies were
fundamentally unstoppable.
- Well, they wouldn't
take it easy on us,
everything was a competition.
Getting to the front seat of
the car was a competition.
The key though, was to not be first,
'cause you were just gonna get
blown up and out of the way.
By someone checking you out of the way.
Or if we ever wanted to tag
along and play with them,
it was well, if you can't keep up,
then you can't play with us.
So that was just our normal growing up.
- Yeah.
- Which brother are you closest to?
- [Jocelyne] Which one?
- I would say it's different,
for different reasons.
- [Gary] Of course.
- And, depending on, two of
them still play overseas.
- [Gary] That's awesome, where?
- One's going to Germany
now and the other,
the oldest, Phil, he's in Austria
and the youngest one is
going to Germany now.
Was in Austria, so.
- Of the four of them who thinks,
what's the debate of who's the,
of the six kids, what is the macro debate?
Net, net.
Don't give me the politically correct,
oh, she's the best at skating and
he was the best of puck, like
who is considered of the six
in the family dynamics,
your own little text
chain or dinner table.
Inevitably, there has to be a
debate of net, net rankings.
- Well Phil was a goalie
so he doesn't count.
- [Gary] He doesn't count, you're right.
- He's out, and then.
- How does he feel about that?
- He was, I.
- [Gary] Why was he a goalie?
- [Sisters] Our dad was a goalie.
- And was he the oldest?
- Yes.
- [Gary] Makes all the sense in the world.
- So if you got in, we
would play street hockey
so our games would inevitably end,
so either Phil would break
all the goalie sticks
'cause he'd break them over the net,
- 'Cause he's a spaz.
- from playing goalie,
'cause he was a spaz.
- Even though he's always
super low-key and laid-back,
total spaz.
- See, I associate with that.
I'm pretty, in the scheme of things,
don't confuse my energy
with me being pretty chill,
in the way I do things in real life,
but in sports I'm completely unhinged.
To the point where, right now I actually
don't want to do sports anymore really,
because where I've
evolved into is actually,
this is so dark, I genuinely
want to injure people.
- [Jocelyne] You sound like our dad.
- Think about that.
Think about how uncomfortable
that was to come out of my mouth.
That is so remarkably inappropriate
and my genuine truth.
- Well so then our brother,
Jacque would always, kind of
cross the line, a little bit,
with slashing someone.
- He would of hurt somebody.
- He would of hurt someone.
- [Gary] See, I like this family.
- And then Pierre-Paul
was good for,
- I feel like,
I might be the seventh child.
- Pierre-Paul was good to
throw an elbow at someone
and would get mad and
then Mario would just,
I don't know what Mario would do.
- Who'd you guys root for?
The North Stars?
- Not really.
Well, they were gone.
- Oh, yeah, 'cause,
they were in Texas, and then.
- You guys are so young,
Jesus Christ.
(laughing)
- Were they in Dallas and then?
- Dallas, yeah.
- Yeah.
- We're just fans, we just enjoy.
- [Gary] Really, you guys
didn't have a family team?
- Yeah, no die-hard team we cheered, no.
- [Gary] Really, nobody?
- No.
- [Gary] Not dad down?
Nobody had a team?
- Well, Phil I guess, like
the Leaves, but we we're just.
- But, back to our dad, he would,
when we were playing checking,
if someone got the best
of us or knocked us over,
he goes, "You don't get
back, you get even,"
- You get better.
- Yeah, you--
- You get them back better.
- Yeah or just, if you're
gonna take a penalty,
he goes, make it worth it, type of thing,
so growing up that way--
- Make those two minutes worth it.
- In high school, college and a little bit
on the national team, like that,
we would get ourselves
a little bit of trouble,
sometimes 'cause we were
just like I'm gonna...
- [Gary] Beat the fuck out of somebody?
- I'll show you.
I'll show you, yeah, type thing and then,
my dad's like, "Why did you do that?"
And then you think back and it was like
for so many years your dad was
tellin' you all these things.
(laughing)
- Who's the best player
that you played against?
Just for your own, just your own personal,
each of you, I'm just curious.
What gal, and it could be at any level,
like when you got the boarding school
or in an Olympic game or a
singular game, obviously,
that one goalie that stood on her head.
- [Monique] Yeah.
- But in a net, net.
I'm just actually, just
genuinely fascinated.
- I think, on team Canada,
Megan Augusta, I think,
year in and year out has been
one of their best players
and kinda has been a
little under the radar,
in my opinion, or I would say,
underappreciated a little bit.
And I think she--
- [Gary] 'Cause you see
the subtle things she does?
- Yeah, well she's just consistently,
- On the score sheet.
- on the score sheet,
all the time and...
I think, one of our coaches last year
had asked, "Okay, who are we
watchin' for, on their team?"
and I was like number two, thinking,
- [Gary] Like, how do
you not understand that?
- 'Cause, obviously Captain Poulin,
she scored two goals in
Vancouver, we lost, two nothing.
She scored two goals when we're in Sochi,
when we lost three, two, of course,
everyone's paying attention her.
- Yeah, but I'm like,
Augusta, she's pretty good,
she's doing pretty good.
- Which team which team,
globally, is emerging?
- [Sisters] Finland.
- [Gary] Finland?
- Yep.
- Yeah, so this last year
at the World Championships,
every World Championships
has been a U.S. Canada final,
except this year was a U.S. Finland final,
which went to a shootout
so Finland's quickly--
- [Gary] Emerging?
- They've been pretty good
and then the last year and a half or so
they've really stepped up
and everyone just assumes
it's a U.S. Canada final.
- And we're are we on the landscape of a
professional women's league globally?
- We're workin' on it right now,
so I don't know how familiar you are with
what's transpired.
- I'm not, but Budweiser is
our client at VaynerMedia
and we had a very
interesting campaign that we
just launched, you might have saw.
- Interesting's a subtle way to put it.
I mean, we think it's amazing.
- Thank you.
So, we're really excited about it.
We recognized what I'm sure you know,
very extreme in soccer and
definitely to a lesser degree,
but clearly in culture from my standpoint,
happens to the Olympic
women's hockey team,
which is and then the
next yay, or devastation
and then the next day we'll
see you in four years.
- [Jocelyne] Yep.
- When we had the hypothesis,
when I saw the team working on it
and they came up with a
great idea to support it
post the World Cup, I did my own Googling,
because I'm pretty in
tune with a lot of things,
let alone sports, and did not know that
even the league existed, right?
That's full transparency and
then when I looked into it
looking at those attendance numbers
and then just think about the star.
Look, these wrestling figures
are here for a reason.
I actually believe that
any sport can capture
America's attention if you
know how to build superstars.
A lot of what it's been
interesting about watching you,
with Comcast, that's how I think, right?
Tony Hawk, Kelly Slater,
the 1982 NBA Finals was
on tape delay in America.
The 1982 NBA, the 1982 NBA
Finals was not live in America
because there was that
little interest in the NBA
and then David Stern with,
obviously you need Larry
Bird and Magic Johnson
and Michael Jordan to be who
they are, but guess what?
You know, the Iceman, George
Gervin, and Connie Hawkins
and Dr. J were pretty, and Pistol Pete,
were pretty remarkable.
They weren't in a framework
that understood how to build,
it's what's happening to baseball.
America is becoming more
Hispanic, LATAM, every day.
The greatest athletes in American sport,
that are Hispanic, are
in Major League Baseball.
And yet, they don't know
how to use Vladimir Guerrero
or Fernando Tatis Jr. or Javier Baez.
So I'm always fascinated,
I genuinely believe America
is a fame star culture.
And when you have Mike Tyson,
and America cares, boxing's huge
and when you don't, they don't.
And so I genuinely believe,
that women's athletics across the board
are really fascinating at
the professional level,
because I think of it as
star power for the WNBA,
this women's soccer league,
whatever you're about to tell
me about the hockey league,
that to me is like how do we
do what Vince McMahon does?
Which is he makes us care about Hulk Hogan
and Randy the Macho Man
Savage and Andre the Giant,
and they're not even
actually, that's a soap opera.
- Shawn Michaels, the Heartbreak Kid.
- Right?
That's a soap opera and it's a framework,
and so when you have Hulk
Hogan and Macho Man and Andre,
you have an era and then
you go cold for a while,
and then when you're lucky
enough to get the charisma
of Stone Cold Steve Austin and the Rock,
you have that era, right?
- [Jocelyne] The Undertaker.
- That to me is fascinating
about sports in America.
- Well, if you think of hockey,
not just women's hockey,
but I think hockey's the
last professional sport
where it's a team, don't bring
any attention to yourself,
don't have any personality and
I feel hockey's kind of like
the last sport that's finally
kind of being accepting
of that because I mean,
you look at P.K. Subban
and the amount of negative attention
he gets for, well he's off on his own,
he's doing his own, people are
allowed to have personality.
- The NHL was one of VaynerMedia's
first clients in 2009
and I remember Brendan
Shanahan had me come and speak
to all the kids that
were about to get drafted
and I was spitting all
this thoughts about what
social media can do and all
the stuff that is now accepted
and to your point, and it's
the same thing in baseball,
and it's the same thing
for rookies in any sport.
Right?
Us normal people don't
understand the judgment pressures
inside of a locker room
that, go do anything,
that isn't on team and
the NBA is the one place
where that is embraced and
that is the biggest reason
it is exploded in the direction it has,
because there is individualism.
That is accepted while
being able to in-parallel,
hold form, 100%.
- On top of having individualism
and not it being judged,
but then being able to
promote it within the team.
- And letting merit play out, right?
Individualism in basketball
is really fascinating.
Tim Duncan just announced yesterday
he's gonna be an assistant coach.
The level of superstar,
to go to assistant coach,
not head coach hasn't been done
at the level of Tim
Duncan, but that's his DNA.
He was always a quiet superstar, right?
Anyway, nonetheless,
please tell me about it,
'cause I'm actually very fascinated.
What is the current state?
- So, there used to be two
leagues in North America.
So there's a Canadian
league an American league.
- And what were they called,
what were they called?
- CWHL, the Canadian
Women's Hockey League,
so that, they folded in March.
- In the Spring.
So they just folded and then the NWHL,
the National Women's
Hockey League still exists.
There's a team in Minnesota
and then it's three teams
on the East Coast, Buffalo,
New York, and Connecticut.
- Boston, Connecticut, so four.
- Four teams.
- Wait, Boston, Connecticut.
- [Monique] New York.
- There is a New York team.
- And Buffalo, so it's four
teams on the East Coast.
- [Gary] So, there's
five teams in the league?
- There's five teams.
And so that league, we feel is
some of the top players in the world.
We feel like it's not
a sustainable league.
you have to have proof of other insurance,
to be able to play and it's--
- [Gary] Were you guys in that league?
- No.
- We've opted to not play in that league.
- Understood.
When did that league start?
- Four years ago.
- Four or five years ago.
- I see, so it started
at a time where you were
in a different place
in your career as well.
- Yes, yeah and I mean, it's just not.
We're both married.
- We're not moving to a different city
to go play for $2,000.
- 10 grand.
- Right, that was to my point.
I mean, it would have been
an interesting conversation
potentially at 22.
It would have been interesting
how you have debated it,
its values and its merits but understood.
- So right now, currently,
anyone's making,
it's between $4,000 and
$12,000, for the season.
- I understand and the attendance numbers
must be really uncomfortably low.
- [Jocelyne] Yes, I don't know
them off the top of my head.
- [Monique] Minnesota had
decent numbers, but then.
- Decent, as in less than 2000, I believe.
- Around, yeah.
- [Gary] That would make sense
to me, knowing enough about
minor league hockey and
things of that nature.
- [Sisters] Yeah.
- So we have opted, we've
created a players association,
it's an official players association,
it's incorporated and all that
and the top 170 players
are in the Association,
but it's the top players in
the world are a part of it.
And are opting to sit out.
- You're looking to go
backwards?
- We're sitting out.
- You're gonna go backwards
and find the right humans,
to start a league with as partnership?
- [Sisters] Yes.
- Yep, so we're opting.
- Create a sustainable,
we wanna--
- I'm such an entrepreneur.
I'm like, I'm gonna start, like literally
right now I'm like how do I
start a women's hockey league
with this players association?
I'm so one-dimensional, everything's yes.
Okay.
- So that's what we're doing.
- That's fuckin' cool.
So we're currently, the
mission of the PA is
to create playing opportunities
next season while players
sit out of the current
professional situation
in North America, so that's
in short what's going on.
- Good for you.
That's really neat.
I may want to talk to you
about that off podcast.
- [Jocelyne] All right.
- I mean it, I think
it's super interesting.
As we're wrapping up, I want
to give you a few minutes
to talk about things that
you wanted to talk about,
in here, versus me
nerding out on the nuances
of your guys' professional hockey career.
- Well I think, as Monique touched on--
- Let's get one phone
call in too, I apologize.
Go ahead.
- As Monique touched on,
we've done the cheer for the one behind,
that's our mission, that's
what we're all about.
And challenging people to do that,
whether that's in a small
capacity on a day-to-day thing
or it's on a larger capacity,
like we've created a
foundation to try and truly
make a tangible difference,
something that we can see,
but it's also being able to
raise awareness around issues
and not being afraid
to speak about things.
- [Gary] Will you guys
be picking those issues?
- [Jocelyne] Sorry.
- [Monique] For the foundation?
- Yeah, like when you say.
- [Monique] Yeah, we've kept it vague,
where we basically can,
we want to be able to pick
and choose what we want to give back to.
- [Gary] What you get passionate about.
- So one of the things
we've been talking about
is the school lunch program.
So if we're looking at how we're,
might be able to fund that
in our in our hometown
'cause some of the schools are like,
it's over 80% qualify for
free and reduced school lunch
and so if we can give back to those,
so at a fundamental level,
kids are expected to
go to school and learn.
If you're hungry, it's
pretty hard to learn.
- [Gary] Yes it is.
- So I know how I am, when I get hangry,
so I imagine kids are havin'
a tough time learning.
- [Gary] I totally understand.
- Just at a fundamental
level, if we can get kids
just starting at the same
point as everybody else,
at an education standpoint,
I think that's something
we're pretty passionate about.
- We're can get the call ready.
I wanna do a quick speed round
while we get this first
call in, first and last.
What are you binge watching?
- You know, with the--
- Stranger Things, I did that one.
- I'm still with the six month old,
I don't binge watch anything.
- [Gary] Zero, I get it.
- But I'm like two episodes
into Stranger Things.
- [Gary] Two is better than zero.
- Chernobyl was a good one.
- [Gary] Oh my God, everybody
hitting me up about that
and since I got lucky enough
and left that area right
before it happened.
Almost, yeah, very lucky.
One more second, I apologize.
What about your favorite
social media platform?
- I like Instagram.
- I think different ones
for different reasons.
So I feel Facebook is more friend friends,
that you actually know.
Instagram, more visual, day-to-day.
And then Twitter if you want
to catch up on the news,
or sort of educational.
- Or events going on.
- But, you play with all three.
- [Sisters] Yeah.
- Yeah, cool, all right.
Yeah, we lost it,
so I'll get one more bench
question while you type.
Who was your favorite athlete growing up?
No politically correct
answers this time missy.
- Jackie Joyner-Kersee was definitely one.
Our mom gave us her book,
so she would have been,
we were too young to
remember her competing.
- [Gary] I remember.
- But, we actually got to meet her
at one of our Comcast events.
- She was gangster.
That's awesome.
- Yeah, we got to meet her last year
and we were just like, oh my god.
- You couldn't wait to take that picture
and send it to your mom.
- Yes.
- Yeah, actually, we brought
her on her trip with us.
- So Jackie Joyner-Kersee, for you?
- I was gonna say I love
gymnastics in the Olympics,
so the, was it the Magnificent Seven?
- Yeah.
- I mean, we still nerd
out over the Olympics.
- [Gary] Love it.
- [Woman] This is Helen.
- [Gary] Who?
- [Woman] Helen.
- [Gary] Helen?
- [Jocelyne] Oh, Helen,
she must (mumbles).
(phone ringing)
- Jackie Joyner-Kersee, so good.
Such an athlete.
- [Woman On Phone] Hello?
- Helen?
- [Woman On Phone] No.
- You're on the AskGaryVee
show, how are you?
And she hung up.
All right, Helen was.
Let's call her, no I want to call,
hold on this is a moment.
Call her right back.
- Did she say no?
- She's, go ahead.
- [Monique] Did she say no?
- I think she was stunned.
Oh, you think she said no and we dialed
the number wrong or it's--
- [Man] I think she couldn't hear you.
- Got it, let's try it again.
- [Monique] It's Helen from work.
- This is really good.
Way to power that.
- [Jocelyne] Is it a 701 number?
(phone ringing)
- [Woman] No.
- It's a 614.
This is exciting now.
Come on, Helen.
- [Monique] She's gonna
put us to voicemail.
- [Woman On Phone] Hello?
- Helen?
- [Woman On Phone] No, this is not Helen.
- Oh I'm sorry, I will
not call you again, sorry.
(all laughing)
- Okay.
- Andy?
(all laughing)
All right, let's go to the next one.
You clearly mistyped that.
- [Jocelyne] Not Helen.
- It's tough, for your first call ever.
You wore this amazing banana shirt today.
You're like, got this big at bat.
Who's this?
- [Woman] This is Ryan.
- Ryan?
- [Monique] Okay, it's Ryan.
- [Ryan] Holy crap, are you serious?
- We are not joking, Ryan.
Say hello, please.
- [Jocelyne] What's up Ryan?
- [Monique] Hi, Ryan.
- [Ryan] Hey, it's Ryan
Snyder, how's it goin'?
- How are you?
- Doin' really well.
What can we answer for you, brother?
- [Ryan] Hey, so I have twin
girls, three year old girls.
- [Monique] All right.
- It's a good start.
- [Ryan] Yeah, right? (laughing)
And I am trying my best
to instill confidence
in them at an early age,
allowing them to be as individuals,
but also at the same time
building the uniqueness
as twins as well and so
my question is also to
you guys and also to Gary
too, you have a daughter.
And my question is how do I build
that confidence in them as individuals,
but also at the same time
allow their uniqueness
to flow as twins as well?
- Great question.
- Well, I'll take the
confidence piece of it,
and I don't think as three-year-olds,
I think you do the best
you can as a parent
to teach them right from wrong
and you let them struggle
within a certain capacity,
so they learn to be independent
and learn how to do things on their own.
- Problem solve.
- Yeah problem solve, but
confidence as you get older,
it's not something someone can give you
and it's not something someone
can take away from you,
and I think that's how you
build security and confidence
and it's not something that
should change day-to-day.
Obviously, your confidence
can go up and down
with different things going
on in life but I think,
that's a tough thing that
adults struggle with every day.
- Yeah, I think of when we
were younger our dad always,
we would call it the face
in the mirror speech,
so whatever it was that we were doing,
whether it was a game, school,
whatever activity we
were in, it was always,
if you can look yourself in the mirror
and say you did the best you can
or you put your best foot forward,
and you worked your hardest
then even though the outcome
might not be what you wanted
it to be, you can be
satisfied with your effort
and you can't be disappointed in yourself,
and I think by having that mindset,
I think that helps create confidence.
As far as the twin question goes,
our parents always put
everything in us together.
And we just always did everything together
and our mom always said,
"Two is better than one."
So we were always unique in that aspect,
that we have the same group of friends,
we did all the same sports and whatnot,
and some twins don't get along like that
(kids yelling)
or spend a lot of time together--
- [Gary] I think the girls
like that answer.
- So I think just letting.
Yeah, I think just letting
that develop over time,
'cause they might end up
having all the same interests,
they might not and as they get older
and their personalities develop,
I think that you'll kind
of find your way with that.
- [Ryan] Awesome, thank you very much.
- Yeah, just add my two cents,
'cause I'm super passionate about,
obviously, I really can't speak
with any authority on the twin level,
(laughing)
but there are two things
that stand out to me.
Number one, I do think reverse engineering
individuals at scale is something
I'm very passionate about.
Having all these different employees
and there's so many different
dynamics and I think it is
a fine line between the
two is better than one,
which I think, the
optimism that that breeds,
I think is incredible and I think is,
it's always better to lean into optimism
versus pessimism and cynicism,
but where I'm about to go with
the rest of that sentence,
is actually the answer to confidence.
I think the number one vulnerability
in society is delusion.
I think that parents are creating
a remarkable level of delusion
over the last 20 years,
because parents have
become so micro-managing
of their kids' feelings and
actually know their day-to-days
too much and are trying to
protect them from the world,
which unfortunately is
fundamentally impossible
and I believe that we have
one to two full generations,
right now, that are closer to zoo animals
than they are humans.
And so as I was listening to the stories,
as we were talking here,
I think one of the great
things that is true about
the three of us' upbringing
was we were in frameworks,
because of circumstances,
where losing wasn't demonized
or protected against, it was
the merit of the outcome,
which got us comfortable with the idea of,
which meant by the time
we were actually 22,
we actually knew that that
was part of the variable
and it is remarkably stunning to me
to watch the enormity of 22 year olds
that go into the world who
demonize and fear losing
or setbacks, because they've
been in an over-coddled,
fake framework environment,
where grades have been the only variable
or seventh place trophies feel
close to a first-place trophy
or mommy and daddy pay
for Uber or the apartment
and we are just in a
very entitled ecosystem.
I think the biggest thing you can do for
those three-year-olds, to create
self-esteem and confidence,
is to make them be in an
environment where losing is reality
and almost even put on a pedestal,
without it being something
that they dwell on,
post the outcome.
- You have to learn how to
fail and learn how to lose,
and learn from it.
- In a real way, not in a fake way.
The amount of parents
that I'm watching, like,
Gary, they hear me talking about this,
and they'll give me the
full 15 sentence email
and it's like, "I let my kids lose",
and then it's some convoluted fake loss.
- [Monique] Yeah.
- Like, they lost in
color wars, this summer.
I'm like, bro, cool but let's
really get in underneath this,
and this gets into,
athletics is fascinating.
The amount of parents
that are so delusional
thinking their kid's going to the league.
(Jocelyne groans)
Yeah, this is why you're
reacting like this,
as an actual professional athlete.
Breaking news, everybody
listening and watching right now,
your kid's not going to the league.
- Whatever league that is.
- Whatever league that
is, because the math is
uncomfortably against you
and so the amount of parents
that are wrapping their self-esteem
into their kids' outcomes in school
and in sports, this is one
huge game of mass insecurity,
at the parent level.
You want those two girls to be happy?
Never let your mom, siblings, teachers,
or best friends points-of-view
on your children ever penetrate your mind.
- [Ryan] That's awesome.
Yeah and that's that's one thing that
I really tried my hardest
at, even with them,
just he basics of falling,
I instantly say to them,
hey, that was a fantastic fall, you fell,
yeah, you gotta scrape, you got a boo-boo,
that sucks, but let's continue
forward and let's continue--
- And you need to find
the balance between,
probably what these two
amazing gals grew up with
which was, there was no fantastic
fall words out of their dad's mouth.
There was get the fuck up, out of their--
- Yeah or you just get ignored.
- Yeah, so I do think,
this is, and by the way,
let me just say this
as I keep on this rant.
Giving parenting advice is
the least interesting thing on earth.
It's just not interesting,
but it's a fun macro
debate, not a micro debate.
So, before I go any further, you do you.
However, my point of view, in the macro,
is all of us have to decide
what a fantastic boo-boo is,
versus a, boo-boos are
real, here's a band-aid,
let's go and everything in between.
I think we're in a culture right now
where fantastic boo-boo
is very much more common
and it's politically incorrect
to do what their dad did
or what I believe in
of like get the fuck up
and you ought to know your kid,
and some kids respond incredibly
well to get the fuck up,
some don't, you got to
stay in listening mode.
But this is just real life,
this is just real life.
I think my mom is the
greatest mother of all time.
I'm the byproduct of it
and the one time my mom
tried to enter a conversation
of how I should parent,
it was a three second conversation
of shut the fuck up mom.
And I realized when I did that to somebody
who I think is my hero,
is the best mom on earth,
I was excited because I was like, wow,
I really believe in the
shit that I talk about.
I am not gonna let anybody
penetrate my mindset.
It's very cute that you
fly in on the weekends,
once in a while and have a point-of-view.
You're not here 24, it's the same reason
that I even walk, tread
lightly with my opinions,
to my wife who's there
actually every second
versus me flying in on the weekends.
It's the one place I'm
like, fuck this sucks,
for me to stay and not be a hypocrite,
I got to be thoughtful here.
That's what I would say bro.
Kids and everybody needs to feel safe,
but not entitled and that fucking
fine line is hard as fuck,
but if you keep repeating that sentence,
it allows you to have multiple moves.
The biggest issue that parents
have now is they've one move.
I think if you go fantastic boo-boo
and get the fuck up and you mix them up,
you've got a much better
chance than one or the other.
- [Ryan] And that's the main reason why I,
- [Jocelyne] I like that.
- Right, that was interesting.
- get up and going.
- I never said that
before, I like that too.
- They have to keep up and get going,
'cause I've seen these
kids, time and time again,
where they'll sit in one spot
and just cry for 10 minutes
about this one boo-boo,
where there's plenty more opportunities
to go ahead and keep playing
and move forward too.
- I've already convinced my six-year-old,
who lives for basketball,
that he will never dunk
and that took two months of
being okay with him, I mean.
He's also his dad's son, he cries 24/7.
All my emotional intelligence,
now is my greatest strength,
but from six to 15, I couldn't
control feeling everything.
And so I just fucking cried.
Every single thing I lost in,
from 1982 to 1989, I cried.
Pool, cried.
Football, cried.
Tennis, cried.
Cried, cried for kids that got picked on.
That's why I love you so much.
Cried for kids that got
picked on in school.
A kid's getting picked on at lunch
and I'm over here crying for that person.
(sisters laughing)
Like couldn't control them, so
my son's got that thing too.
So telling him he's not gonna dunk now,
is painful as fuck.
Most parents don't want micro-pain.
They don't realize they're
creating macro pain.
It hurts hell watching
him cry for 20 minutes,
full steam, of basically, fuck you daddy,
why can't I dunk, and the
answer's genetics, bro.
It's just not gonna happen, but he also,
and this is crazy for me to say,
I can't even believe this happened,
he almost actually beat me
in Pop-A-Shot basketball
this weekend, because his
jump shot is so insane,
'cause he stopped dunking
on his little fucking thing,
after I finally got through to him
and he's shooting from such range
and his euro-step and
his left hand and now,
he will be an unbelievably
good pickup basketball player
one day and that's awesome.
So to me, that's something
parents need to bring
into the framework, versus
what I see 90% doing,
which is the reverse of what I just did,
which is you'll dunk one
day son, you're gonna dunk,
and then me paying, because of my ability,
NBA coaches to teach him,
when he's in eighth grade,
on one-on-one and then
somewhere around 15,
he's like I'm fucking delusional.
- Well, if you just use sports, for us,
it's a microcosm of life,
you use it to teach being a good teammate,
take direction from others,
listen to your coaches,
having a good attitude, working hard,
accountability, all
those things transcend--
- You want to talk about one that,
I know we're so over and I got a run,
but you know what my favorite one is
and I'm sure you've done this.
You know what my favorite
thing that people learn about
in sports that nobody ever says out loud?
Knowing when not to listen to a coach.
I've never heard anybody say
that and when I watch kids
or just watching, I'm like (snaps).
Like, I literally watch
that way, like I watch.
I've hired people here when they've
been interns, by the way they've played.
Nate is my partner in Empathy Wines,
because as an intern the
way he played volleyball
made me know he would be
good and it played out.
I'm being serious.
Knowing when to not listen
to the coach is such a subtle skill.
- But be respectful at the same time.
- [Gary] Correct, well it's funny--
- And you pretend like you're listening.
- No, no you nailed it, you know what?
I think about this.
I was the most disruptive force
in my classrooms from
third grade to senior year.
In our senior breakfast, which
was a really cool tradition
at our high school,
somebody got up and said,
"My favorite thing about high school
"was hoping I was in
Gary Vaynerchuk's class
"'cause I knew that he would always waste
"seven to 13 minutes per class."
(sisters laughing)
The fact that I was able to do that
and still be liked by my
teachers is now in hindsight
so much of what I am,
similar to what you just said
which is knowing when not
to listen to the coach,
but not being an issue.
- Yep, exactly and then you just--
- 'Cause players on the field still know.
And that confidence, so anyway,
nonetheless, thanks for the call.
Ladies, thank you so
much for being on the,
so abrupt the way we hung up.
(laughing)
I really appreciate.
This is really fun,
this is how we wrap up,
you get to ask the question of the day,
any question you want for
the audience, fire away.
- We were talking,
we kind of touched on
it a little bit earlier
but in women's professional sports,
doesn't have to be hockey,
what do you think is the tipping point
to bringing it to the next level?
I think you're starting to
see in the NWSL right now,
but what do you as a
professional entrepreneur,
what do you think?
- Well they're gonna answer it.
- [Jocelyne] Oh, Yeah.
- Yeah, they're gonna answer it,
you'll get thousands of
comments and you'll see that.
- If you're in your mom's
basement and you're 40,
just don't even bother commenting
and saying whatever you have to say.
- You mean, you're going
cliche the other way,
of a disrespectful comment?
- Yeah, oh yeah.
Don't even bother.
- Yeah, I mean honestly,
thank you for that question
and I'll leave it with this PS.
It's where I went earlier.
I actually think under the radar sports
are far more interesting to me.
I'm far more interested in things
that aren't top five right
now, because what they don't,
people don't understand that
ninja matters for eSports
even though it's Fortnight
and not necessarily
even Overwatch or league
or League of Legends,
like it's star power.
That's what's gonna take
it to the next level.
It's Jackie Joyner-Kersee,
it's long nails,
its Mary Lou Retton, it's these things.
It's what the Olympics do.
They take America and they
do a mini-documentary.
It's what 24/7 was for boxing.
Right, it got people that
had no interest seeing,
like wait a minute Manny
Pacquiao's got a cute little kid?
I'm rooting for, it's story
telling in contemporary places.
The reason I got excited about, ooh,
maybe I should get
involved this league is,
I'm okay and then I'll
do a deal with Facebook
and it will only air on Facebook
because that's where the new attention is
and that's just cable,
which helped other sports.
It's about storytelling and attention,
but I'll let them answer.
(laughing)
Awesome, I'm good.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- [Gary] Thank you,
guys, that was super fun.